first of all i have to say you know
michael myers frightens a lot of people
the film was horrifying as per usual um
what frightens you does it change every
year
you know the truth is i've i've spent a
lot of time uh in this genre it's not a
genre i like personally i i i'm not a
fan of being scared but what i've
learned in the process of of playing
lori strode is that i scare easily
i am by nature if i if i if we had more
time i would get my phone i would show
you a picture of me as a child yeah as
an infant i look terrified
there is something
i am i scare easily and i think it's a
natural response and i think the fact
that it's natural is why i've been
successful at it it's not manufactured
yeah you can tell it doesn't really
matter what is the thing i scare easily
oh
what was it like being on set again with
kyle richards i know that she was with
you in like 1978
well i carried kyle richards in the
original movie i carry her literally
physically i carry her
um the last moment of her shooting of
that movie i carried her to her trailer
like she and i bonded so when i was told
by the filmmakers that they were going
to make a movie not just about lori
strode's trauma but about the collective
trauma of the town of haddenfield and
the other people who were terrorized by
michael myers and
that lindsay was going to be played
again by kyle yeah um was just thrilling
for me because she's such a an
extraordinary woman she has been in a
long marriage she's
philanthropic and very generous
and a wonderful mommy of four young
women so she's a great example of
tenacity and surviving show business to
really um and she's gorgeous yeah i mean
like
crazy town gorgeous
kyle said she broke her no her nose
while filming this new movie have you
ever broken anything over the years
doing these films oh yes mommy mommy yes
mommy
yes you you know there is a there is a
it's not something
you know that you you talk about very
much because it's part and parcel to the
work i broke my ribs in the 2018 movie
uh in two places actually
um
because that's what happens because this
is real you know stunts are stunts and
um the all of the protections are put in
place and sometimes you get to wear
padding and sometimes you don't yeah and
sometimes in the heat of the moment
something happens
and
that's what happens and i think it also
is what makes these movies so
good is that there is a feeling of
actual
um
risk
no pain no gain
you know um i i think that it's part and
parcel there's not a person i know
in any sort of action movie horror movie
any sort of genre movie who has not
gotten hurt
it's the
it's part of the
it's part of it you try to ameliorate it
as much as possible but that's
impossible yeah
i loved the way you fiercely defended
scarlett johansson just the way that you
support women every time i talk to you
is always amazing to me um would you
love to work with scarlett johansson i
would love to see it
i would you know i'm i'm older
um than these young women and
it's unlikely that there will be
something where i will align with
scarlett um i have always admired her
way prior to her playing my mother in
the hitchcock movie um i've always just
thought of her
as don't want to say fearless because
she's been so vulnerable on screen that
she has shown great empathy and emotion
um
but she's just excuse my french effing
cool
she's cool yeah and i'm i'm was asked to
write about her in time magazine
i have always thought she was cool and i
and i think what she's doing and saying
in this lawsuit is is important
and you know women who speak up are
called
[ __ ] and you know
uh strident and men who speak up are
called heroes yeah so um i'm gonna stand
with the women
i love that thank you so much thank you
thank you god bless you and give lu my
love to all my canadian friends yes god
bless you we love you in canada this is
awesome thank you
you